former National Security Advisor Michael
Flynn is exonerated by the Justice
Department Democrats insist on continued
lockdown with no alternative plan and
Tara Reid speaks out I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show this show
is sponsored by Express at VPN don't
like the government spying on you well
visit Express at VPN dot-com slash Ben
to stay anonymous okay so we will get to
everything coronavirus related because
the new economic reports are just as
stunning and shocking as people thought
they would be we now have great
depression level unemployment in this
country we went over the course of six
weeks from three point five percent
unemployment to fourteen point seven
percent unemployment which are levels
not recorded since the Great Depression
are we allowed to talk about ending this
lockdown yet are we allowed to talk
about it or are you just gonna scream
that we're killing grandma if we even
have discussions about how to
responsibly
reopen we will get to that but the big
story of the day yesterday is that the
Department of Justice dropped the case
against Michael Flynn president Trump's
former national security adviser to
recap what happened with Michael Flynn
basically Michael Flynn had been put in
place as the national security adviser
the incoming national security adviser
for President Trump there were fairly
significant questions about whether that
was a good pick considering that Michael
Flynn was very friendly with Russia
today he was very friendly with the
government of Turkey there are questions
about those sorts of associations but
aside from that he had a call with
Sergey kis lyac who was the Russian
ambassador that was not illegal he was
the incoming Trump National Security
Advisor not illegal for him to talk to
Sergey kis lyac apparently he was
talking with kids lyac about sanctions
with regard to Israel or un UN sanctions
with regard to Israel UN resolutions
with regard to Israel that was happening
simultaneous with the Obama
administration attempting at the very
last minute to basically pull the rug
out from under Israel so he was calling
up kis lyac and they were having a
negotiation about all of this he was
called in front of the FBI the FBI went
and visited with him and when they
visited with him they said don't worry
we're not investigating you or anybody
close to you we're just here for like a
friendly chat and in the middle of that
chat they asked him whether he'd had a
conversation with kis lyac this is in
the middle of the entire Trump his
Russian catspaw obviously this election
only went the way it did because of
Russian interference and they asked him
if he had talked with kis lyac and he
said he had not talked with kis Lea and
the meantime by the way they had been
basically threatening him that if he had
talked of kiss like he might have
violated the Logan act the Logan Act is
a century and a half old piece of
legislation that is overwhelmingly
believed to be by legal scholars
unconstitutional it basically says that
if you're an American citizen you can't
carry out your own foreign policy not
only is he an American citizen though he
was the incoming National Security
Advisor there's nothing remotely illegal
about him talking with the Russian
ambassador so he fibbed to the FBI my
dad is the part that is undisputed as he
fib to the FBI then it comes out that
there all sorts of documents that make
it look like the FBI is attempting to
get him to fib to the FBI simply said
they can then turn him against other
members of the Trump administration and
maybe start moving up the food chain
toward President Trump in their quixotic
quest to get Trump on Trump Russia
collusion well it turns out that after
three years of this basically
bankrupting Michael Flynn after three
years of him being in danger of having
to go to jail for violation of fibbing
to the FBI and I say fibbing as opposed
to lying because it's it's sort of a fib
when you lie about something non
material it is a lie when you when you
lie about something material like
there's an underlying crime did you do
the drug deal like nope didn't do the
drug deal turns out you did the drug
deal right that's lying to the FBI in
pursuit of a crime if they ask you did
you eat ice cream yesterday and you're
like nope didn't eat ice cream yesterday
eating ice cream was not a crime that's
why I'm using the term fibbing as
opposed to lying I am deliberately
downplaying the extent of the lie
because I do not think that this was a
material lie and neither did the DOJ
according to National Review the Justice
Department yesterday moved to withdraw
its case against the former Trump
national security advisor sending newly
discovered and disclosed information
according to a new court filing the move
was first reported by The Associated
Press it came less than an hour after
the top prosecutor on the case again in
Brandon Vondrak submitted his withdrawal
from the case it's pretty obvious he
knew what was coming down the pike and
he decide he was gonna withdraw as a
sign of protest the decision said that
the White House interview Flynn gave to
the FBI which ultimately led to his
guilty plea was conducted without any
legitimate investigative basis in other
words even before the FBI went and
talked with Flynn
there have been recommendations to shut
down any investigation of Flynn and then
they reopened it specifically because
they thought that perhaps they could
sort of bully Flynn into either lime or
into turning on people inside the Trump
administration we'll get to more of this
in just one second because this is
leading to accusations of politicization
of the DOJ the only thing I can say to
that is have you heard of Janet Reno the
former attorney general under Bill
Clinton have you
I'm Eric Holder have you heard of
Loretta Lynch that's not what about
isn't it's just to point out that if
this goj is politicized which i think
frankly this is a less politicized DOJ
than anything coming out of the Obama
administration if you're talking about
the dangers of a politicized DOJ you
might want to start a little bit earlier
than the last five minutes anyway we'll
get to all that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that now with
this level of economic uncertainty you
need to be on top of your business
you just cannot afford to not approach
your business in granular fashion
particularly when it comes to your data
you need to know everything there is to
know about your business this is why you
need NetSuite by Oracle it's the world's
number one cloud business system with
NetSuite we give you financials cash
flow payroll inventory and more all in
one place so you have clear visibility
and total control of your business
NetSuite customers have the flexibility
to work from anywhere with media clarity
on critical information directly at
their fingertips no more guessing no
more waiting make smarter decisions with
confidence because you know everything
there is to know about your business
join over 20,000 companies who trust
NetSuite to stay in control here at the
daily wire we are focused in
extraordinary fashion on our data but we
also don't have a hairball systems if
you've got a hairball systems you're
doing ten different systems to keep
track your data you're making a mistake
head on over to NetSuite right now
receive your free guide managing
business uncertainty schedule your free
product tour right now at NetSuite comm
slash Schapiro don't wait to get that
free guide schedule your free product or
NetSuite comm slash up hero and ETSU IT
e-comm slash appear Oh
NetSuite comm slash apparel get that
free guide managing business uncertainty
schedule that free product tour right
now NetSuite comm slash apparel stay on
top of the content that you need about
your own business over at NetSuite okay
so the DOJ puts out a decision letter
and the decision letter says that get
that Flynn entered a guilty plea which
is since sought to withdraw to a single
count of making false statements in
January 24th 2017 interview with
investigators of the FBI this crime
however requires a statement to not be
simply false
but materially false with respect to a
matter under investigation that is the
law again it has to be false with
respect to a matter under investigation
the government has determined pursuant
to the principles of federal prosecution
based on extensive review that continued
prosecution of this case would not sort
of the interest of Justice materiality
said the said the DOJ is an essential
element of the offense materiality
moreover requires more than mere
relevance or relatedness to the matter
being invested
it requires probative weight whereby the
statement is reasonably likely to
influence the tribunal in making a
determination required to be made and
they're saying that this is not
something that happened they say after a
considered review of all the facts and
circumstances of this case including
newly discovered and disclosed
information appended to the defendants
supplemental pleadings and basically it
was only in the last couple of weeks
that the government finally turned over
to the defense all of these relevant
documents the government has concluded
that the interview of Flynn was
untethered to and unjustified by the
FBI's counterintelligence investigation
into mr. Flynn a no longer justifiably
predicated investigation that the FBI
had in the bureau's own words prepared
to close because it because it had
yielded in absence of any derogatory of
them information in early January the
FBI had said we're gonna close it this
thing the government is not persuaded
that the January 24th 2017 interview was
conducted with a legitimate
investigative basis and therefore does
not believe mr. Flynn statements were
material even if untrue moreover we we
do not believe that the government can
approve either the relevant false
statements or their materiality beyond a
reasonable doubt so here is the
background as the DOJ lays it out the
FBI opened a counterintelligence
investigation into Flynn on August 16th
2016 as part of the larger crossfire
hurricane umbrella investigation into
the presidential campaign of President
Trump and it's coordination with Russian
officials codenamed a crossfire raiser
the investigation stated goal was to
determine whether Flynn was directed and
controlled by and/or coordinated
activities with the Russian Federation
in a manner which is a threat to the
national security or possible violation
of the foreign agents Registration Act
in addition to the predication for
opening crossfire hurricane which didn't
identify Flynn the FBI predicated the
counterintelligence investigation of him
on an articulable factual basis that
consisted of three facts Flynn's service
as a foreign policy adviser to the Trump
campaign his publicly documented
connections to state-affiliated Russian
entities and the fact that he traveled
to Russia in December 2015 now after
four months of Investigation the FBI
came up with nothing and they found that
he was no longer a viable candidate as
part of the larger crossfire hurricane
umbrella case they prepared to close at
the investigation at some point prior to
January 4th 2017 the FBI even crafted a
closing communication to effect
determination of the case the document
noted the specific goal and predication
for the investigation and laid out the
numerous searches of holdings and
investigative steps that yielded no
derogatory information
on Flynn it stated that the
investigation had failed to produce any
information on which to predicate
further investigative efforts and noted
no interview a Flynn was required as
part of the case closing procedure and
then they said the FBI is closing the
investigation before the intended case
closing I shoulda took effect the FBI
learned that Flynn had talked to his
lyac in December 2016 by this time of
course Flynn had already been named by
Trump the incoming National Security
Advisor the FBI had the transcripts with
the relevant calls believing that the
counterintelligence of Flynn was to be
closed the FBI leadership determined to
continue its investigation of Flynn on
the basis of the calls and considered
opening a new criminal investigation
based solely on the Logan Act and this
is where he got into complete BS again
Logan axe has not been prosecuted
successfully in a hundred years like
really it's never been prosecuted
successfully not once On January 4 2017
FBI deputy assistant director Peter
struck learned that the closure had not
been timely executed the
counterintelligence an investigation
into Flynn was formally still open
struck immediately relayed the
serendipitously good news to lisa page
the special counsel to FBI director
Andrew McCabe remarking our utter
incompetence actually helps us page
reacted with surprise and relief struck
instructed agents to keep it open for
now at the behest of the seventh floor
struck indicated there was a need to
decide what to do with him other
internal FBI messages from that
afternoon reflect apparently related
conversations about a potential
interview as of January 4th the FBI kept
its counterintelligence investigation in
to Flynn based solely open based solely
on his calls with kis lyac On January
12th the Washington Post reported those
communications between Flynn and kis
lyac the next day Sean Spicer
spokesperson for the Trump transition
clarified the communications had
involved only logistics that seemed to
contradict the nature of the calls and
then VP pence stated in a news interview
that Flynn had suggested his
conversation with kis Lee Act did not
relate to sanctions around that time FBI
director Comey advised DOJ leadership of
its investigation into Flynn and senior
officials at the FBI and DOJ had
concerns that the incumbent White House
officials descriptions of Flynn's calls
with kis Lee Act were not accurate Comey
took the position the FBI would not
notify the incoming Trump administration
of the Flynn kiss lay out communications
okay so now what we have is they think
that Flynn lied to members of the
administration but they have the
transcripts of the calls they know that
he didn't do anything that actually
violated the Logan Act or broke the law
but they're seeing daylight between the
Trump administration
and Flynn and this is when you get into
do we want to get Flynn fired so that we
can get him to testify against other
members of the Trump administration or
do we want to catch him in a lie
said he's consistent with what he has
told other members of the Trump
administration and then we can catch him
in a lie and we can threaten him so that
he'll turn on members of the Trump
administration that seems to be the
logic here Deputy Attorney General Sally
Yates and other goj officials believe
that the incoming administration should
be notified but Comey
said no Yates and another senior DOJ
official became frustrated when commis
justification for withholding the
information from the Trump
administration repeatedly morphed
vacillating from a potential compromise
of a counterintelligence investigation
to the protection of a port purported
criminal investigation the Deputy
Attorney General DNI and director of
Central Intelligence Agency all agree
the FBI should notify the incoming Trump
administration of what had actually been
said on the calls come he refused to
brief the White House because Comey
apparently was just thoroughly convinced
that the Russians were playing the Trump
administration and he didn't want to tip
them off so the fact that investigation
was going on so the only I mean kommen
should have been fired like for thwip
this is ridiculous stuff from James
Comey who's busy posturing presumably in
the woods right now matters came to a
head January 24th 2017 this is all the
DOJ letter that morning Yates contacted
director Comey's and a man the FBI
notify the White House of the
communication so Yates who's been sort
of dragged through the mud by the Trump
administration to a certain extent
Yates actually wanted the FBI to notify
the White House director Comey didn't
return the call when Comey called her
back later that day he advised her FBI
agents were already on their way to the
White House to interview Flynn Yates was
flabbergasted and dumbfounded other
senior DOJ officials hit the roof upon
learning of that development saying an
interview of Flint should have been
coordinated with the DOJ in fact senior
officials at the FBI had been engaged in
discussions of how to approach Flynn and
whom to notify on January 21st 2017
struck proposed to bill pre-snap the
FBI's counterintelligence chief that
Flynn should be given a defensive
briefing about an investigation under
the crossfire hurricane umbrella or
alternatively an interview under light
defensive briefing pretext struck noted
that the DOJ might direct us to inform
the vice president or somebody else and
they didn't want to do that and they
wouldn't explain why they didn't want to
tell the Trump administration on January
22nd if an FBI attorney emailed strucken
page that if we usually tell the White
House I think we ought to do what we
normally do though the official noted
that they could be told that not to
debrief our interview Flynn
in advance of the interview Comey
determined they would go interview Flynn
the following day without notifying
either the DOJ or the White House in a
December 2018 interview he said that
this was something we I probably
wouldn't have done or gotten away with
in a more organized administration
okay then messages between struck and
page indicated that pre-snap had
conducted several conversations that
Hannity McCabe because he wanted to know
why we had to go aggressively doing
these things openly on the morning of
January 24th follow-up messages between
struck and page indicated the pre-snap
brought it up again in front of Comey
and McCabe was frustrated and cut him
off in any event McCabe called Flynn to
arrange the interview he explained the
recent media statements about his
contacts with KISS lyac merited a
sit-down and they said that they wanted
to do this quickly quietly discreetly as
possible Flynn was unguarded in the
interview he viewed the agents as allies
when interviewing Flynn struck and the
other agent didn't show him the
transcripts of the calls nor did the
agents give it any point warnings that
makings false statements would be a
crime and normally in these sorts of
situations you want to give the person
fair warning there about two why
specifically because you already know
that they have lied in the past so you
sort of want to put all that out there
didn't want to do that the basic idea
here was that they were going to
essentially catch Flynn out and then
they were going to use him
according to the FBI agents
recollections when acted asked if Flynn
recalled to any conversation in which he
encouraged his Lackey not to escalate
the situation in response to American
sanctions Flynn responded uncertainly
stating not really I don't remember it
wasn't don't do anything Flynn also
stated although it was possible he
didn't recall any conversation in which
the Ambassador stated that Russia would
moderate its response due to Flynn's
request meanwhile when asked if you were
called asking countries to take certain
actions on that UN vote on Israeli
settlements Flynn explained the
conversations were along the lines of
where do you stand on what's your
position after the interview the FBI
agents expressed uncertainty as to
whether Flynn had actually lied FBI
agents reported to their leadership that
Flynn exhibited a very sure demeanor and
didn't give any indicators of deception
both of the agents had the impression
Flynn wasn't lying or didn't think he
was lying when Comey was asked do you
believe Flynn lied Comey said I don't
know I think there's an argument he made
he lied it's a close one on November
30th 2017 the special counsels office
filed a criminal information against
Flynn charging him with that single
count of making false statements Flynn
pled guilty to the offense okay so the
the question as to the law is whether
there is materiality here they say that
it is not just that you have to tell a
lie you have to show that there was
materiality to the underlying
investigation in the case of mr. Flint
says the DOJ the evidence shows his
statements were not material to any
viable counterintelligence investigation
or any investigation for that matter
initiated by the FBI the FBI had
recognized it lacked sufficient basis to
sustain its initial counterintelligence
investigation they found no derogatory
information on Flynn the communications
in Flynn and kis lyac did not warrant
either continuing that existing
counterintelligence investigation or
opening a new criminal investigation the
calls were entirely appropriate on their
face Flynn never disputed the calls were
made indeed Flynn as former dia as he
was director of defense intelligence
agency would have readily expected the
FBI had known of the calls in the words
of one senior DOJ official it seemed
logical there may be some communication
between an incoming administration and
their foreign partners and there was
nothing said on the calls to indicate
anything inappropriate going on also the
FBI knew the contents of the calls with
no dispute as to what was said there was
no factual basis for the predication of
a new counterintelligence investigation
and they didn't open a criminal
investigation based on Flynn's calls
with kis lyac predicated on the Logan
Act in fact they never attempted to open
a Logan Act investigation on these
grounds
Flynn's communications implicated no
crime okay so they decide that they're
going to let this thing go and the
reason they're gonna let this thing go
is because again there was really no
criminal activity here this has set off
an absolute firestorm the idea here is
that Flynn presumably should have been
prosecuted because it's unusual for the
DOJ after a guilty plea to actually just
release the person we'll get to that in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that if you are not actively
protecting your data online right now
you are doing something wrong the fact
is that you're used to working at work
and you have IT departments that help
you protect your data when you're at
work but now you're working from home
and you're online 24 hours a day and you
know who else is online hackers people
who want that information they want to
steal your credit card information they
want to steal information about you and
they want to use it against you that's
why even at home I never go online
without using Express VPN expressvpn
makes sure your ISP cannot see what
sites you visit instead your internet
connection is rerouted through
expressvpn secures secure servers each
Express VPN server has an IP address
that's shared among thousands of users
which means everything you do is
anonymized it can't be traced back to
you expressvpn also encrypts 100% of
your data with best-in-class encryption
so
your information is always protected use
the internet with confidence from your
computer tablet or smartphone expressvpn
has you covered on every device you
simply tap one button and you are now
protected so protect your online
activity today with a VPN I trust to
secure my privacy visit my special link
expressive VPN comm slash man you're
doing something dumb if you don't and
when you use my special link expressvpn
dot-com slash pen you get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
expressive VPN comm slash pen expr ESS
VPN comm slash been to learn more go
check them out right now expressvpn comm
slash man okay so the flynn release has
basically set off a firestorm the idea
here is that bill barr the Attorney
General is doing something deeply deeply
terrible because he's going back on the
do J's initial prosecution of Flynn or
threat of prosecution of Flynn to get
him to bargain to a a plea deal right he
originally pled guilty back in 2017 and
now they're abdicating basically they're
just getting rid of the case and so
people are mad about it Julie O'Sullivan
former federal prosecutor who teaches
criminal law says I've been practicing
for more time than I care to admit I've
never seen anything like this the case
against Flynn was originally brought
about by the office of the former
Special Counsel robert muller it had
become a political cause for Trump and
his supporters bar instead
short-circuited the case on Thursday
Timothy Shea the interim US Attorney in
the District of Columbia told the judge
overseeing the case the prosecutors were
throwing it that's because the
department could not prove to a jury
that Flynn's admitted lies to the FBI or
material the move essentially erases
Flynn's guilty plea because he was never
sentenced and the government is not
willing to pursue the matter further
the prosecution is virtually certain
certain certain dad although the judge
could still decide whether to grant the
department's request to dismiss it with
prejudice it could theoretically be
refiled in the future if the judge
decides differently apartment have been
a lot more honest at Samuel Buell a
former federal prosecutor who now
teaches criminal law at Duke University
Peale says the walk regarding what
counts as material is extremely
forgiving to the government the idea is
that law enforcement is permitted to
pursue criminal theories of criminality
and to interview people without having
firmly established there was a crime
first yeah but if you just like five
seconds ago said you were dismissing the
entire investigation against somebody
and then you are just relieved that it's
still technically open so you can try to
you know I mean basically they're trying
to flip Flynn against other people in
the Trump administration because they
here's the bottom line it looks like
there were people including combing
inside the DOJ and the FBI at the time
who were firmly convinced that Trump
Russia collusion had happened and now it
was just a matter of raising the
evidence so as to go get Trump and so
Flynn was just a tool in that he was
just a way of going after going after
Trump and or removing Flynn from the
process because as the national security
adviser he would be overseeing the
investigation itself in some ways would
be able to protect Trump against some of
the investigation that's the theory of
Andrew McCarthy over at National Review
so the DOJ saying listen we're not going
forward with this yes it's unusual for
the DOJ to do this you know what else is
really unusual prosecuting the National
Security Adviser on the basis of a Logan
Act fib
okay the Logan Act is not a thing it's
not a thing and the idea that the Logan
Act was supposedly the predicate for
going and getting him to lie so that you
could go after him and get him out of
the chain of command is really
incredible it doesn't remind faith in
the institution in the first place I
mean the the fact that they went forward
with something like this on the basis of
your incoming national security adviser
talked with the Russians and then didn't
tell everything in the call to vice
president pence and that this is
material lie in a criminal case yeah
good good luck with that in court number
one but beyond that the the fact that
this was being carried out by holdovers
from the Obama administration does not
exactly create a level of trust and this
is particularly true when we find out
from Fox News that President Obama was
aware of the details of that incoming
national security adviser Michael
Flynn's intercepted December 2016 phone
calls with Russian ambassador Sergei
kiss Leah
apparently surprising Deputy Attorney
General Sally Yates according to
documents released on Thursday
apparently Obama was an intimate
knowledge of the details of Flynn's call
Obama personally had warned the Trump
administration against hiring Flynn made
clear he was not a fan Obama had fired
Flynn as head of the DIA in 2014
Obama cited insubordination Flynn said
that he was pushed out because of his
aggressive stance on combatting Islamic
extremism on January 5th 2017 Yates
attended an oval office meeting with
Comey
and Biden and Brennan and DNI James
clapper
they were discussing Russian election
interference after the briefing Obama
asked Yates incoming to stay behind he
said he had learned the information
about Flynn and his conversation with
Russia
Bassitt are about sanctions this would
have been the day after the request to
end the case right
Obama specified he did not want to any
additional information on the manner but
was seeking information on whether the
White House should be treating Flynn any
differently given the information so
there are two ways of reading that one
is should the White House be shutting
Flint off to information cuz you guys
think he's a criminal and that's an
honest question the other is so I've
been hearing through the grapevine that
basically this case is coming to an end
and I see that there's this call out
there maybe you shouldn't let this case
come to an end we don't exactly know
what was said
apparently Yates had no idea what the
president was talking about apparently
Yates was being gone she's the Deputy
Attorney General they were going
directly around her Yates recalled Comey
mentioning the Logan Act I can't recall
if he specified there was an
investigation Comey did not talk about
prosecution in the meeting I mean it's
pretty amazing
the FBI suggests by the way why exactly
Flynn was originally prosecuted
basically because he was on Trump's team
because he had been on Russia today and
because he went to Russia in December
that's like the whole thing so this
whole case was thinly predicated in the
very first place and all the objections
that this was somehow this somehow this
is really a destruction of legitimacy of
the DOJ to drop a case that was those
thin to begin with and it really was
dedicated to removing all obstacles
between them all our investigation and
Trump in a case that was poorly
predicated itself that's a mistake
all righty coming up we're gonna get you
everything coronavirus related we'll get
to that in just one second first let us
talk about your sleep quality so I will
admit to you that this is a very
stressful time for everybody and also
when you are home with your kids that
means that you're just are not getting
enough hours of sleep my kids are going
to bed too late they're waking up too
early when I'm on the helix sleep
mattress however those are moments of
heaven helix sleep a mattress made just
for me helix sleep has a quiz and takes
just two minutes to complete matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you whether you
are a side sleeper or hot sleeper
whether you like a plush or firm bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated be number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just head on over to helix sleep calm
/ban take their 2 minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they've got a 10 year warranty
you have to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix is
offering up to $200 off all mattress
orders right now for my listeners again
toner bucks
at helix sleep calm at /bin that is
helix sleep calm slash man go check them
out right now ten year warranty tried
out for a hundred nights for us free
twenty bucks off of me doesn't get
better than that
helix sleep calm slash man for a
mattress personalized to you really
isn't amazing mattress helix sleep calm
slash Ben alrighty so meanwhile the the
corona virus situation continues to
develop in incredibly incredibly foolish
ways and when I say that it's it's
developing an incredibly foolish ways
what I mean is it is now clear that we
have flattened the curve as much as we
are going to flatten the cover these
lock downs so you've been hearing all
sorts of basically media lies about the
elevation of cases oh we're not we're
not locking this thing down New York
starting to climb but everywhere else is
not starting to decline okay you can't
do it the way the media's doing it
they're doing an absolute number of
cases rising outside of New York okay
here's an actual chart showing the
number of daily positives declining as a
percentage of the actual test that is
the question right the if you take a
look at the daily positives declining
chart from Scott Gottlieb that's what I
want right the u.s. daily positivity
rate over time is declining so what you
see here is that there was a sharp rise
between basically March 13th and April
10th or so which makes sense because
those are the two weeks following
lockdown so the infection is still
running rampant and you're starting to
see the testing increases and you're
starting to see people testing positive
more often and now you're starting to
see a fairly sharp decline to the point
where we are now in terms of daily
positivity test right we are now down
around 10% we're up at about 20% so it's
been halved so that's a pretty solid
flattening of the curve that has
happened right there and then so what
this raises the question of is what
exactly are we attempting to do now
right we we've we've locked it down
right we had the lockdown we flatten the
curve and in flattening the curve we
completely flatten the economy the
economy has completely flatlined layoffs
have now topped 33 million in the United
States 33 million the unemployment rate
in the United States is now 14 at 0.7
percent these are great depression
levels of unemployment JPMorgan is
suggesting it will take ten years for
the economy to recover the jobs that it
lost just in the last month and a half
alone yeah I realize to discuss risks
and trade-offs anymore are we allowed to
do that now or
are we going to continue to do this
routine where if we talk about opening
up at all then we are going to then
we're killing grandma so up for the
folks who are pushing lockdown it is
obvious this is a political ploy Andrew
Cuomo continues to play this game the
worth really he's a terrible Governor
Andrew Cuomo it's incredible man has an
approval rating in the 80s he has
mishandled this worse than any
government governor in America worse
than Gavin Newsom
worse than any of the Republicans who
are brought under under scrutiny Ron de
santis is riding in the mid-50s right
now Ron de santis handled this way
better than anybody else okay Ron de
santis basically said listen we're only
gonna shut down when we feel the
necessity to shut down everyplace else
stays open and yes we'll do social
distancing I'm not gonna treat the
panhandle of Florida the same way that
I'm going to treat Miami and South Beach
the stance is yesterday for example he
said listen people should be outdoors
they should be on beaches as long as
they're staying away from each other
there's no evidence of outdoor
transmission we have virtually no
evidence of any outdoor transmissions
leading to outbreaks be it a beach be it
a golf course the fishing anything that
Florida is known for the transmission is
typically occurred in enclosed
environments when you have repeated
contact with someone such as in the home
and so our policy was never to try to
drive people indoors it does show the
incredible power of the media that
DeSantis is down in the mid-50s
well dumbass Governor Andrew Cuomo who's
been awful awful I mean the fact that he
gets on TV and he tells you the bad news
he only has the luxury of telling you
the bad news because he can blame Trump
at the top of the government but I mean
when he says stuff like he's such a
demagogue when he says stuff like you
know every life is priceless again every
life is priceless in terms of its moral
worth when it comes to actually
calculating public policy nobody
suggests that we have to mitigate all
risks down to zero and this seems to be
the newfangled thought here is that
we're gonna mitigate all risks down to
zero you can't come out of your homes
you can't start to go back to work with
social distancing we can't protect that
we're gonna just stay lockdown forever
until the risks go back to zero to
abolish death right Joe Biden tweeted
out and it's not worth one life it's not
worth one life to raise the Dow Jones
Industrial Average one point okay well
then I suppose that we should probably
just all abandon our jobs and then we
can sit in our homes and we can farm
dirt in our backyard sound sound good we
can go back to pre civilization era when
everybody's life expectancy was 35 I
mean I guess that's a good old
if you're a so you're Andrew
Cuomo's suggesting yesterday yeah we're
not going to choose between the health
and health and the economy
we're just there's no choice it's a
false choice whenever people suggest in
politics that a choice is a false choice
typically they mean that it's just a
choice they don't actually want to talk
about here's Andrew Cuomo avoiding
responsibility for making choices that
he's gonna have to make if it's about
money we can we'll figure it out but you
have to have your health that's why
public health versus the economy I don't
see the trade-off we have to have our
health we should protect human life I
don't care if a person is old
you know I'm old by your definition I
still think I have a value right my
mother's old you know she's the most
precious person to me so protect every
life and I'm not going to trade off
public health and we'll figure out the
dollars and we'll figure out the
economic impact what a cheap and lazy
political point of view I mean that is
just cheap lazy demagoguery of course
every life has value of course I've got
parents who are in their 60s you think I
want them to plotz nobody wants me I've
grandmother's who are in their 90's do
you think I want them to plots of course
I don't want them to plots nobody wants
anybody to die the question is what are
the risks that we as a society are
willing to undertake to allow an economy
to function
hey this is complete idiocy the way that
this is being discussed complete idiocy
and by the way I don't want to hear from
Andrew Cuomo about how dedicated he is
to protecting the elderly when you
wouldn't even protect the damn nursing
homes let me show you some stats from
these nursing homes because they're
insane finish it let me tell you some
stats from the nursing homes okay so by
country here are the percentage of kovin
19 deaths taking place in nursing homes
is across world ok 25 percent of all
deaths in Australia were in nursing
homes 62 percent in Canada 33 percent in
Denmark 51 percent in France 36 percent
in Germany 60 percent in Ireland 32
percent in Israel forty percent in
Portugal 45 percent in Sweden
okay and then if you look at the united
states what you're going to see is
similar statistics in the united states
by state
8 58 percent of deaths nursing homes
Connecticut 55 percent Delaware 65
percent Florida 38 percent Georgia 48
percent Indiana 35 percent Kentucky 57
percent Louisiana 37 percent Minnesota
Mississippi 47 44% New Hampshire 77%
Oklahoma 43% Rhode Island 76% Tennessee
25% Wisconsin 42% New Jersey is
reporting that their their death share
is actually now 50% Pennsylvania is up
to is up to 68 percent Virginia is 59
percent nursing homes New York we don't
know because New York refuses to report
these statistics
why does New York refuse to report the
statistics because then Andrew Cuomo
might be forced to recognize that his
dumbass policy of we are going to force
nursing homes to take back in people
with kovat 19 killed a lot of people
here was Andrew Cuomo being asked about
his state handling of the nursing homes
and completely you know just watching it
we knew the nursing homes were going to
be a target and whatever we do they will
be a target our people are doing
everything they can do we have the
equipment we have the staff they're
doing everything they could do okay
they're doing everything they can do
well they're doing everything that they
can do in light of the fact that your
regulations are garbage but here's the
bottom line would you actually like to
protect the people who are dying from
koba 19 protect the nursing homes that
is task number one is protected nursing
homes and then we need to trans people
back into work and we need to do it
forthwith and there's nothing more lazy
than this idea that if you loosen lock
down if you let people go back to work
that it's gonna be like 911 never done
is what Al Gore was saying al gore is
out there yesterday saying it'll be just
like 9/11 every day provide me an
alternative I've not yet heard an
alternative from any of you from any of
you like what when the cases get to zero
it ain't happening with 80% asymptomatic
transmission what we're doing 50 million
tests a day when we have contact tracing
for 50 million people in the United
States the hell are you talking about
here's Al Gore being a demagogue when
the University of Washington made these
adjustments they said within a month
we're gonna see 3,000 deaths per day
200,000 new infections each day that's a
911 every single day and ignoring that
thinking that somehow magically that's
not gonna happen
this is a botched reopen it's a botched
reopening
we haven't even reopened yet the hell
are you talking about and how do you
know it's a battery when you haven't
even seen the stats coming out of
Georgia my favorite thing is when the
members of the media start citing
increased testing statistics to cite the
increased number of positives they've
been doing this routine oh look at how
many positives are coming out in Texas
and Florida yes because they're
increasing their testing they're
increasing their testing you idiots okay
in just a second we're gonna get to
actually you know the measures that are
now being taken because they're absurd
they're absurd I'm sorry they're just
absurd and the attitude that's being
taken with regards were leaving lockdown
we have to discuss the fact that 33
million Americans are out of jobs and if
you refuse to recognize this thing you
are abandoning those 33 million
Americans and don't tell me you can fill
them in with the government check you
can't these are people who are losing
their livelihoods they're losing their
dreams they're losing their ability to
feed their children and you're telling
me you're the compassionate one because
you won't even condemn a governor for a
fuzing to protect the nursing homes go
to hell seriously it's ridiculous at
this point we're gonna get to how people
won't even discuss the policy in just
one second first let's talk about the
simple fact that you're spending a lot
of time at home right now
you need to be comfortable but you would
also like to be stylish Tommy John has
something for everyone no matter what
you are working from home situation is
no matter what that situation is from
super soft and breathable underwear for
answering emails in bed to loungewear
for when you're running to get takeout
Tommy John is here to keep you
comfortable right now Tommy John is
offering all customers 25% off site-wide
treat yourself and upgrade to a few
pairs of Tommy John underwear in the
softest most breeze breathable fabrics
you have ever worn all of their
loungewear leggings are built for next
level comfort whether you're in the hunt
for lounge pants sleep shorts or lazing
around joggers Tommy John has got you
covered they also make great Mother's
Day gifts my wife loves time John
products I mean their female products
are just fantastic Tommy John is so
confident in their product if you don't
love your first pair of underwear you
get a full refund with their best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guarantee
Tommy John no adjustment needed there's
a reason my wife is only allowing me to
get her Tommy John from now on hurry -
Tommy John calm /ban for 25% off your
order
that's Tommy John calm /ban for 25% off
orders Tommy John calm /ban CE site for
details it's a great deal for the best
pair of underwear on the market and all
the rest of their loungewear which is
also fantastic stuff go check out Tommy
John comm slash Ben right
all right we're gonna get back into the
politics of lockdown in just one second
because it is fairly obvious that there
are a lot of people who are basically
comfortable with lockdown because what
they would like more than anything else
is to completely Rican wife you're
starting to see this from members of the
Democratic Party
Ayana Presley and Rashad Robinson have a
piece over a USA Today basically
suggesting just that San Francisco has a
few measures of its own all of this is
craziness we'll get to it in a second
first it is that glorious time of the
week when I gave a shout-out to a daily
why remember today it is Linda Morgan on
Twitter she's doing quarantined
schooling right in this picture
Linda's husband is diligently helping
their happy son with his schoolwork
while holding the world's greatest
beverage vessel in one hand and a second
glorious tumbler resting on the computer
desk that is the way to do it the
caption reads real daily where when both
your parents are teachers there is no
relief from home learning thank goodness
for the refreshing taste of leftist
years hashtag leftist tears tumblr
hashtag daily where hashtag it's got
electrolytes true true fantastic his
test scores will improve twofold
with two times the tumblers thanks for
the pick Linda keep up the good work now
is also a good time to tell you about
the Daily wires newest most exclusive
membership tear the all-access insider
the all-access insider memberships here
is our premium level of membership all
access members gets all benefits of our
other membership tiers you get that ad
free website experience all of our live
broadcasts our show library including
the mailbags the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show with the dedicated
editorials from me but you also get
other amazing benefits including we left
this tears tumblr you also get to join
the live exclusive online Q&A Zardi lee
weyer a new discussion feature available
on both the website and the app also you
get to participate in our
extraordinarily popular I'll access live
that is our our brand-new show that
we've been doing every single day one of
our hosts every single day will hang out
with you 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
I'm on tonight who knows what craziness
will ensue will I play tunes on my on my
face will i whistle for you well I will
I flex my who knows it could it could
get crazy guys well I dress up as Darth
Vader who knows what insanity will ensue
head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe to join daily wires all-access
club with the new membership or an
upgrade get 10% off with coupon code
Shapiro that is daily wire.com slash
subscribe see you there you're listening
to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so these lockdowns of course come along
with the disadvantage of having to
enforce at the lock downs and the
general rule is if you don't want to
enforce a rule then don't put the rule
in place in the first place if you want
to hand people a ticket for a fine hand
people a ticket for a fine but if you
don't feel like tackling people in the
middle of New York or attack elect
people on the streets of New Jersey
well then probably you shouldn't tell
people in the police force that they
need to do exactly that
also other bad ideas policing the
ice-cream ants is a thing that happened
yesterday there's a local news affiliate
that was broadcasting out the face of an
ice cream truck driver who is not
practicing social distancing he was not
who's driving around in his ice cream
truck he was not wearing a mask and he
was handing children the least
vulnerable members of our population
prepackaged frozen treats I mean
unbelievable the level of viciousness of
this human clearly he should be featured
on local media and we should make him an
outlaw probably we should put him on the
FBI ten most wanted because when I think
of like severe dangers handing people
ice cream outside with you know distance
between you that's naturally created by
you know being inside a truck and
handling stuff to people outside clearly
this guy is just what what a terrible
person here was the local CBS Chicago
report on this dude's a good idea to be
doing this with the stay at home order
covered 19 eventually our Greg got a bit
closer tried to get an answer for mr.
freeze again the village manager tells
us if you see that ice cream man call
9-1-1 call 9-1-1 mr. freeze he's on the
loose again meanwhile over in Texas
Shelley Luthor who is the salon owner
who was engaged in you know social
distancing and responsibly opening her
business like a few days early and a
judge tried to throw her in jail for a
week and find her seven thousand dollars
she walked out of jail to LA to loud
applause yesterday which is good news
but here's the thing the pedal is gonna
the Rubbermaid is gonna meet the road
here okay there's just no way for you to
to enforce these sorts of things without
actual without actual
police enforcement are you willing to do
that are you willing are you willing to
throw people in jail for not wearing a
mask in public areas well providing
cannabis to the homeless in San
Francisco this is a thing they're
actually doing okay according to the San
Francisco Chronicle
san Francisco's Health Department
confirmed on Wednesday that the city was
administering Alcohol Tobacco medical
cannabis and other substances and in
efforts to prevent a handful of people
quarantine or isolating in city leased
hotels from going outside to get the
substances themselves so it's great now
we have home delivery by the government
of illegal medications to people to
homeless people who are living in hotels
at the expense of the government great
policy excellent excellent policy I mean
I'm sorry this this is insanity
especially if you were gonna say that
sure we have to we have to be harsh on
this because it's really it's flattening
the curve we are really making sure that
we are stopping this thing if you got a
plan then let's hear the plan but I
haven't heard a plan yet so yesterday I
briefly discussed the fact that there is
no actual plan here that we were told to
go into lockdown and don't worry guys
there would be a plan and then it turns
out the plan doesn't exist and the
reason the plan doesn't exist is because
we don't actually know what's going to
happen over the course of the next year
now we have a series of models and they
tell us what's gonna happen one month
out but this is basically irrelevant
it's basically irrelevant what's going
to happen one month out because we know
that if people leave lockdown there will
be an additional number of infections
that is just the thing that is going to
happen so yesterday I actually put
together in colorful fashion the chart
of what I'm talking about so you can see
exactly to what I am referring okay so
here is the here's the chart the basic
idea here is that there are three curves
for folks who cannot see there's a pink
curve there is a blue curve and there is
a green curve okay the the and then
there is a red line across the middle of
the page that shows medical capacity the
three curves represent three different
strategies of how to handle this thing
the pink curve was uncontrolled spread
right the uncontrolled spread was
basically just let everybody go about
willy-nilly is gonna be huge spike in
cases and everybody's gettin infected
and then a lot of people are going to
die because you're going to rise above
the medical capacity right and you don't
want that because all the people above
the medical capacity might have been
able to survive if you would not
overwhelm the medical capacity right
then and that's what we did we flattened
the curve so now we're arguing about
which curve we want so we want this blue
curve or do we want the green curve the
blue
Rises faster and declines faster it
doesn't overwhelm medical capacity it
rises faster and it declines faster and
then there's the green curve which rises
slower and decline slower over time the
number of infections and thus the number
of deaths under both the blue curve and
the green curve because they do not
overwhelm medical capacity number of
infections and as a percentage of the
infections the number of deaths should
be the same over time so here's what the
media are doing so they can lie to you
about how lockdowns are the end of the
world he'll lockdowns are the only
available solution and if you don't lock
down you want to kill grandma what
they're doing is they're showing you
models that cut off in June 2020 it is
the vertical line that you see on the
left hand side of the screen and that
vertical line says June 2020 now if you
cut off the screen in June 2020 what you
would see is a huge number of cases and
therefore deaths under the blue strategy
right which is make sure that people in
nursing homes are taken care of make
sure that elderly people stay home make
sure that there is some form of social
distancing specifically for people who
are most vulnerable but everybody else
you know if you want to go to a ball
game with a bunch of 20 year olds and
then there are some infections in all
likelihood you will be fine because the
odds of you getting really sick and
really low right that is pursuing herd
immunity and faster fashion it's
front-loading the herd immunity so if
you front-load the herd immunity
you're also front-loading the infections
so if you cut off the model at June 2020
what you see is that there would be a
lot fewer people infected and a lot
fewer people dead by the by the
beginning of June 2020 under the heavy
lockdown heavy social distancing model
then under the controlled Avalanche
model but now move forward to June 2020
ones who move forward a year and what do
you see what you see is that the number
of infections and the number of dead are
basically the same in the blue model and
the green model is just that it was
spread out longer over the green model
right the area under the two cars is the
same meaning the number of infections
the number of dead is basically the same
so long as you don't overwhelm the
medical capacity the difference between
the blue model and the green model is
that the blue model involves reopening
the economy in heavier fashion right not
destroying the entire world economy and
the green model involves continuing to
destroy the entire world economy so here
are your choices same number of people
dead over the course of the next year
you may save a few months for people but
essentially same number of people
infected and same number of people dead
over the course of the next year but
front-loaded to the pain is now versus
spread out over time so that instead of
2,000 deaths today
get 1,000 deaths today and then six
months from now you're still getting
1000 deaths today and in the other model
you're now getting to hundreds out today
because you went up and then you went
down right and in one case you didn't
kill the economy and in one case you did
kill the economy these are the sorts of
choices that have to be made right now
now what the left will say is that the
blue curve does not actually exist right
that it is only a choice between full
lockdown and full release and that is
not true
it is just not true now the other
counter-argument that I've seen here is
that you would have to that it's very
difficult to do anything like the sort
of controlled Avalanche strategy that
I've been talking about because you get
what you call epidemic overshoot right
what that means is that lets say that
herd immunity happens at 60% but let's
say that the thing spreads faster then
you can actually control it so you may
end up with eighty percent of the
population infected when you only needed
sixty percent of the population infected
to achieve herd immunity right so if you
did it slowly it gradually ease up to
sixty percent
herd immunity would be achieved and then
the other forty percent of people are
protected okay but if you allow people
to go out willy-nilly then you might
achieve herd immunity but because the
thing is spreading so fast you get
people who are infected who wouldn't
have been infected if you had done this
slowly that's true but if you involve
yourself in social distancing the way
that Sweden has and you approach it more
slowly then you're probably not gonna
get tremendous levels of epidemic
overshoot right the key is how do you
get to herd immunity without that
tremendous epidemic overshoot now it is
possible and this is sort of the the
unspoken assumption that the green curve
is better than the blue curve if there's
a therapeutic or vaccine develop now
people are way too sanguine about the
possibility of a very effective vaccine
here even Bill Gates has been pushing
vaccinations
he says that the chances of developing
like a super effective vaccine are not
super over the course in the next twelve
months are not supremely high the flu
vaccine is used by about half of
Americans it's only forty five percent
effective for those who use it even
well-known vaccines like pertussis
vaccine those create a certain level of
herd immunity and that's important but
they're only about eighty percent
effective for people who actually take
the vaccine and they're not in an in
fact secure all so you're assuming that
there will be a therapeutic treatment or
that there will be a vaccine that fix
everything if you're not assuming that
then you have to start thinking about
what you can do to get past the pain of
the health situation in order to ensure
that we have a functioning economy
because guess what not only are you get
deaths of despair you're gonna get
enormous numbers of people in poverty
you're gonna have ruined lives in the
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions within six weeks basically
every small business in America will
fail you can't just keep signing checks
for this sort of stuff forever so what
is the alternative I keep hearing people
like well you're saying lockdown needs
to end too early okay you tell me when
do you think it's safe for lockdown to
end and nobody will give you an answer
instead it's okay when when we flatten
the curve we flatten the curve okay
it'll be when there's a testing and
tracing procedure in place that's
capable of what of what testing and
tracing procedure capable of doing what
and nobody will explain that because the
testing and tracing procedures are
supposed to prevent the overwhelming of
the healthcare system which again was
the presupposition of the blue curve in
the chart that I just showed you the
presupposition of the blue curve is that
it doesn't overwhelm medical a medical
capacity so that's what you need the
testing and tracing for you don't need
it to get the rate down to zero there is
no world in which we get the rate down
to zero so how about this how about we
recognize the cost of what we are doing
I'm sick of hearing there no costs what
we are doing when they're clearly costs
in reality there's a certain number of
people who are deeply deeply comfortable
with all of this they're there they're
deeply comfortable and I'm talking about
people like Ayanna Presley apparently
from Massachusetts she has a piece in
USA Today called congresswoman called in
post coronavirus world politics has to
change
she says the question is how will
respond will we once again let fear and
worry take over and drive us toward
choices that take us backward or will we
rise to the calling of this moment it's
a man that we replace the principles
that define our society today like
inequality with the principles of
humanity and justice that will help us
all succeed in other words if we
continue the lockdown guess what there's
gonna be an ordinate pressure from
massive government intervention ISM
universal basic income government
subsidization of everybody at
extraordinary levels there are some
people who are very comfortable with
lockdown because they actually like the
consequences of the full-scale lockdown
that is not something that is acceptable
that is not acceptable to me and I'm not
going to stay in lockdown just that you
can pursue your socialist utopia and
guess what neither are most Americans it
is one thing to stay in lockdown based
on expert advice as to how many lives
this is going to save over the course of
the next year not over the course of the
next two weeks but I want to hear those
estimates and I want to hear your plan
for reopening in responsible fashion
because so far all I hear is people
shrieking like banshees every time
somebody actually
tries to make a calculation his hand
with headlines like this one David
Axelrod Donald Trump's cold hard
political calculation weird cuz I'm here
any calculation from folks on the
Democratic side I just your demagoguery
our plan is that no one dies ever again
in human history and all you have to do
is give up all of your freedoms forever
and we'll tell you when you can be free
again no I'm sorry the answer is no no
nobody is offering a solution nobody
it's just a bunch of demagogic nonsense
already time for some things that I hate
we'll start with things I hate today
I've been advised by my producer Colton
that people like things I hate better
than they like things I like so we will
do things I hate today
first okay so things that I hate I have
to I have to acknowledge that Joe Biden
his campaign is just it's an awful
campaign a truly awful campaign so
yesterday Joe Biden had a virtual Town
Hall it was not good it was not a good
Town Hall
basically it failed technically on every
single level involved Joe Biden trying
to work a computer which is never a good
idea here was Joe Biden trying to
determine whether he was honoring a
virtual rally in Tampa Florida here was
Joe Biden being confused as to what
computers are and why they didn't exist
when he was a child please walk Vice
President Biden
that's okay guys that is that is not us
there those cutouts there that's not our
technical fault that is his technical
fault and the thing was glitching and he
didn't know whether he was on and he
somehow liked sitting in the back of the
room and then he sort of randomly
approaches the camera yeah good good
look right there
I will admit I did appreciate the
squawking bird interrupting Biden and
and giving the most authoritative
commentary of the day here's actually
what it sounded like when a squawking
bird just started sounding off in the
middle of this response to avoid these
desperate outcomes and they're not only
desperate they're there they affect
people in so many different ways so the
floods can actually reach people in
communities and small businesses you
know they're supposed to be helping
okay good good job by campaign other
things that the Biden campaign is
handling just top-notch the Tara Reid
allegation so Tara Reid did a sit-down
with megyn kelly yesterday after the
rest of the media basically said they
wouldn't have her on for weeks and then
finally they said they want to have her
on and she was like you know what after
you rejected me for weeks I'm gonna go
no on that and maybe I'll go over to
somebody who least is gonna be somewhat
more sympathetic to allegations of
sexual assault so here was Tara Reid
yesterday calling for Joe Biden to drop
out of the race
if he's watching this what do you want
to say to him I want to say you and I
were there Joe Biden please step forward
and be held accountable you should not
be running on character for the
president the United States you want him
to withdraw I wish he would but he won't
but I wish he would that's how I feel
emotionally do you want an apology I
think it's a little late okay and then
megyn kelly asked Sarah Reed if she'll
take a polygraph and here was Tara
Reid's answer they also point out that
she took a polygraph controlled by
someone on her team is that something
you want to do I'm not a criminal
Joe Biden should take the polygraph what
kind of precedence is that set for
survivors of violence does that mean
we're presumed guilty and we all have to
take polygraphs
so I will take one if Joe Biden takes
one but I'm not a criminal
okay so the reality is you should say
sure I'm happy to take a polygraph right
I have serious doubts as to Tara Reid's
credibility here I've been saying this
for a while but I had serious doubts as
to Christine Blasi Ford's credibility
like I think serious questions should be
asked of anybody who alleges something
as serious as a full-on sexual assault
the difference is Democrats don't feel
the same way there is certainly more
contemporaneous evidence that Tara Reid
actually even worked for Joe Biden and
made complaints about Joe Biden then
there was with Christine Blasi Ford
according to the merced sun.star taking
this from the taking this apparently
from the Washington Post a court
document from 1996 shows former Senate
staffer Tara Reid told her ex-husband
she was sexually harassed while working
for Joe Biden in 1993 the declaration I
guess it was exclusively obtained by the
Tribune in San Luis Obispo California
does not say that Biden committed the
harassment it doesn't mention
more recent allegations of sexual
assault but the divorce records do say
that there was a quote problem she was
having at work regarding sexual
harassment in US Senator Joe Biden's
office so obviously she was making
allegations of something haven't
happened in Joe Biden's office way back
when
now what's hilarious is the reaction by
Democrats to all of this totally
hypocritical and absurd Dianne Feinstein
the senator who five seconds ago was
saying the Brett cab not should withdraw
his nomination because of questions from
Christine Blasi Ford now she says that
the Cavanaugh situation is totally
different
she says Cavanaugh is under the harshest
inspection we give people over a
substantial period of time what that
what you mean he's I mean one wants to
be president that seems like that might
require an investigation says I don't
know this person at all who's made these
allegations she came out of nowhere
where's you've been all these years he
was vice president to attack him this
way to me is utterly ridiculous it's
unbelievable
that's unbelievable from Dianne
Feinstein remember during the Kavanagh
hearings if you so much as mentioned
that Brett Kavanaugh had been on the DC
Circuit Court of Appeals that had been a
very prominent person in public life for
a long time and that these allegations
were four decades old so where was
Christine Blasi for all this time then
you were considered not to be taking
women seriously Dianne Feinstein says
the exact same stuff about Tara Reid and
it's well she's taking women seriously
she says why didn't she say something
you know when he was chairman of the
Judiciary Committee or after that she
said this is incomparable to Cavanaugh
and then meanwhile senator Amy Klobuchar
was asked about that she says about
Biden he's been forthright he's answered
the questions respectfully I'm proud to
support him asked if she believes Reid
she said I think he's answered all the
questions he's made clear he supports
her rights come forward asked about
criticism Democrats too have a double
standard club a charge didn't answer and
walked into an awaiting car which of
course is exactly what you would expect
from the Democratic Party I mean just
astonishing astonishing stuff so the
Biden campaign has problems of its own
which is why the Democrats are basically
pinning their hopes on the notion that
Trump completely botched the handling of
coronavirus they're hoping that the
economy does not the economy isn't gonna
recover very fast do they have a not
going to say they hope for people to
lose their jobs because I don't think
that all Democrats want people to lose
their jobs what I will say is that
they're in a very comfortable political
situation where if the economy continues
to tank they can just point to Trump
it's very comfortable politically to be
in a position
where you can say if you release us from
lockdown then if one life has lost it's
on you and also lockdown is killing the
economy that's Trump's fault and the
same exact people who are saying that
this new Great Depression is brought on
by Trump are saying that if we relieve
the depression by letting people go back
to work then Trump will be killing
people so they set up an absolute
catch-22 for anybody who actually wants
to mitigate risk to life while also
ensuring that the economy doesn't
full-on die that's gonna that's gonna
have to be the tent peg upon which they
build their entire superstructure here
because Joe Biden does not have a
campaign that is worthy of note I mean
it's just a terrible terrible campaign
okay time for a quick thing that I like
so things that I like today but there's
a good book that I recommend it on
yesterday's radio show by Brad Meltzer
it's called the Lincoln conspiracy it's
it's basically a historical thriller
about the secret plot to kill Abraham
Lincoln the first time he was a there's
a pretty sophisticated plot to kill
President Lincoln right after he had
been elected and not the one that's
where he actually died there was one way
before that the book is really good Brad
Meltzer is terrific I've recommended a
bunch of his books on the program before
I really recommend this one it's a great
kind of interesting and uplifting read
at a time that is neither interesting
nor uplifting so go check out Brad
Meltzer with josh mensch the lincoln
conspiracy the secret plot to kill
America's 16th president and why it
failed okay other things that I like
today so it is good news that the two
georgia men who killed akhmad are berry
I'm out I'm not trying to pronounce his
name unfortunately I'm out our berry the
they were arrested Thursday night on
charges of murder that was two months
after the killing took place on February
23rd they should have their day in court
you should see all the evidence the fact
that for two months no arrest was made
is an indictment of the criminal justice
system in Georgia which seems to me
people are saying it's based on race I
think it's just quite as possible it was
based on on chumminess between the
people who committed the shooting
regular Michael and Travis McMichael and
local law enforcement the the this of
course has some has generated all sorts
of national in intensity it should
generate national intensity and it's a
good thing that this is gonna go before
a grand jury it should have gone before
a grand jury long ago
alrighty so we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise have yourself try to
have a relaxing weekend as one day
bleeds into the next
endlessly as weekdays and weekends
become one long period of miasmatic
waiting otherwise we'll see you here on
Monday try to relax
get on that helix sleep mattress try to
get yourself a few moments of relaxation
with those bull and branch sheets go
check it out and enjoy yourself this is
the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is produced by Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Camino hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you